let's move on to a team that could take
an offensive lineman early in the draft
and that would be the carolina panthers
in a strange spot at number eight
they've signed not signed but traded for
sam darnold so the need for quarterback
isn't as urgent as it was
but they still could take a quarterback
depending upon how the board goes or
they could take the best available
player that's what matt rule the head
coach suggested when they traded for sam
darnold a couple of weeks ago or they
could trade back today scott fitter new
gm of the carolina panthers meeting with
the media discussing the possibility of
doing just that sliding out of the
eighth spot in round one we've talked
several actually already
i'd say it'll
i'd say at least five
all in different parts of the draft
and there'll be a lot more calls this
week
and
yeah we're very open to moving back
we're open to picking it just depends on
how the board falls those first seven
picks in front of us
and that really is the key and what
teams do
they talk to a bunch of other teams
about potential moves and they're
contingent on who's available we heard
from dave gettleman earlier in the week
the giants gm on that's on that topic
where you know he's got this reputation
reality he never trades down well you
know there have been times where we're
ready to trade down but the guy that the
team wanted to trade up for was gone
that's part of it and and once you get
that many pics in the board starts to
take on a life of its own and you never
know who is going to be there so a lot
of options for the carolina panthers and
at some point next thursday night
they're going to have to make a decision
you can have all the options in the
world but you better be ready when the
time comes to make a decision because
you got 10 minutes to do it
right and that's why teams have clusters
of guys basically that they say all
right if we're picking here then this is
who we think we can pick if we're
picking here this is who we think that
we can pick and if none of those guys
are there then yeah we're going to
probably explore every avenue that we
can in order to trade down now i think
that because the panthers now have sam
darnold you know if somebody like trey
lance happens to fall into their lap
justin fields maybe falls into their lap
at number eight overall then yeah i
think that that has to be a serious
consideration especially because look
sam darnold as much as you can say
there's a lot of potential there he also
was by the numbers one of the worst
starting starting quarterbacks in
football last year we can maybe say that
was adam gase maybe it wasn't we don't
quite know so and that's one of the
things about sam darnold that i think
sometimes people forget i know we're not
necessarily talking about sam donald
right now but when he was at usc and i
remember this very well because i was in
los angeles at the time it's not like he
was playing turnover free football okay
so this guy has had turnover problems
going all the way back to college so can
you solve that that's something that the
panthers have to figure out and that's
why i think that if there's a
quarterback there then yeah you're
definitely going to consider him if
that's the guy that you think properly
fits your offense otherwise you
definitely could select somebody like a
raeshawn slater if he's still available
if sewell isn't picked by cincinnati as
i think most of us expect will happen he
could definitely be somebody that the
panthers pick up they're gonna have a
lot of options there mike and i i'm not
sure exactly what they're gonna do i
don't think anybody is i don't think
they are but they're going to have a lot
of options and it'll be interesting to
see how they figure it out
on darnold because another thing federer
said
they'll decide after the draft what to
do about his fifth year option
18.858 million you know it's funny we
see reports
and we accept them as gospel truth and
sometimes they are and sometimes they
aren't for example the report that the
chiefs aren't going to sign orlando
brown to a long-term contract well maybe
they will right until they don't
there's a chance they will
and with darnold there were reports
after that trade was done that the
panthers will exercise the fifth year
option fitter said we'll make that
decision after the draft and
i
hey
miles they could flip sam darnold i mean
i i that wouldn't be out of the question
would it i mean they could they've given
up they've given up three picks for him
two next year a two and a four next year
and a sixth this year
there could be something that happens
between now and may 3rd when they have
the deadline of picking up the option
where they could trade him depending
upon what happens in the draft so uh if
they get a quarterback
maybe they will move on from sam darnold
we just don't know and and even if they
would pick up the option that doesn't
preclude trading am i i think they will
pick up the option if they don't trade
him before may 3rd i don't know why you
wouldn't uh they they invested 33
million in teddy bridgewater they'll
invest 23 million or so in sam darnold
they've already invested three draft
picks in sam darnold but if justin
fields of trade lands fall into their
laps and they want him david tepper the
owner of the team is so determined to
get a franchise quarterback he's willing
to to treat these moves as sunk costs if
need be in the quest for a guy who's
going to be his quarterback for the next
15 years
yeah and that's one of these weird
things where mike i think you're totally
right if something happens and the
quarterback that the the the panthers
thought that they were not going to be
able to get falls into their lap instead
of going at you know one two three or
four um in that first round i guess we
really should say three or four because
we know who the first couple of
quarterbacks are going to be off of the
board basically at this point look then
anything can happen and yeah when you
have somebody like sam darnold you could
in theory move him and you would
probably you know get pennies back on
the dollar that you spent in order to
acquire him but i think that at the same
time if there's something that you know
strikes you that could be a good deal
for you yeah there's no reason why they
couldn't now it's still in the realm of
possibility and so what federer was
saying today you know and that we have a
strong plan and we'll let you know what
that plan is after the draft but right
now we are concentrating on the draft i
mean i think it sort of does invite that
kind of speculation to say well maybe if
something happens that doesn't assume
it's likely to happen but if something
happens then there's going to be a
consequence of that something happening
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports